salut cireur soir vicomte
on peut causer rubinstein arrête le
cheval
tu me cherches tu pensais je t'ai
cherché à toi de firmi non pas cinq
minutes après je sens le bijou de
l'écrin fort va y avoir feu d'artifice
je suis pas pressé pour te faire une
grosse tête
ces gars là tous les jours chez les mets
karine quiche aux lieux et j'ai connu un
petit pas dans ton genre c'était un
bergerac city il causait comme toi trop
depuis j'y porte des fleurs tous les ans
à la douceur des chrysanthèmes dt 6
heures
as tu m'impressionnes pas si rennes est
le patron et ben ali comme ça si race
est un joker et on y cause en sont à 1
10 ils sont car de brige m'ont fait des
tartines et la 10 heures à 1 et s'est
qualifié pour ce môme caramel et si je
faisais une marche mart d'occasions si
je te payer un bon motard âgé en peur
sierra j'ai mon sujet
heureusement apparemment place à quoi
c'est tout tant pis on en a marre on
aurait pu le voir dans le quartier est
affligé annoncé un peu toc et si tu
avais de dollars doris bures l'accord
son buteur est venu aux choses
mais voilà bien vrai corniche au concert
tu veux jouer les gros bras et pis t'as
rien de cigares h 21
nota les bretons et pour montblanc ce
qu'aurait pu dire écoutez je vais lui
refiler à tout faire à repenser sur les
naseaux et sans phone 7 est champion on
le retire l'armée du salut par filer un
cierge à l'enfant de choeur ça aurait
fait rire et il y aura une passe mal
aimés ya toujours de quoi se marrer y
apprend qu'en sierra j'ai vu la môme
roxxor ans tu parles d'une géométrie
s'offre en génie des laisses tomber la
souris ou c'est moi qui mène la voix
charmeuse mauvais tu marches convient de
vie qu'on range met en vrille au
frigidaire celle sont à la taille et
leur distribution va y avoir droit
saladier battez bien avancer maintenant
un bouge pas si rare ou je te couches
dans le muguet fleur de lin d'assumer
ton billet et boutin peut-on faire
parler d'une vraie car post régleront
court qu'en bourgogne on se frottait
monsieur sîrîn aux bergerac stephen de
la bande avait une peau
8 avec la chine qui chassa jean todt le
fils de ta mère en fait qu'en sierra
j'étire vie ce que je te préviens je
range est avec grace mo'fo d'accord ça
part tout seul c'est trop tard jean
claude et syndicales feu nos pères
fouettards thierry coin mathus après 10
heures je travaille toujours au
silencieux qui a un historique ou salade
applicables aux femmes il m'a vu leur
image en le séparant de cause comme
récemment des constats info niveau de
culture aspirations ne fait pas la vache
mon papa chez les têtes en hausse sur
filmée par deux fondateurs sur la grosse
irma voulons non on parle gros colon à
200 greffes et quand j'ai fini de
compter un mais je tatoue chiffre
devrait doubler d'ici là la famille on
voit justement
et